Hi, Emily!
- Hi!
Ich bin Christoph, wie geht's dir?
- Mir geht's gut, und dir?
Mir auch, also lass uns mit dem Interview anfangen
- Klar
Hallo Emily
- Hallo
Danke, dass du heute dabei bist
- Natürlich
Ich frage diese Frage ziemlich oft, aber ich finde es immer wieder interessant:
Ist das hier die erste Online-Talkshow bei der du bist?
Ja, ich glaube schon, dass es die erste ist
- Ja?
Wenn nicht dann würde ich lügen, aber ich
glaube das ist die erste, ziemlich cool
Ok, dann fangen wir mal an, also: Wie ist die Lage?
Alles ist super momentan, das ist glaube ich mein drittes mal in Deutschland
Leider sehe ich nie viel von den Städten, wie Köln
oder München, ich wünschte ich hätte mehr Zeit
Ja? Du hast also immer Termine?
Ja, ich habe immer viel zu tun, ich wünschte
ich könnte mehr sehen... Bist du von...?
- Köln!
Ja, ich bin mal den Kölnturm hochgelaufen
- Gelaufen?
Ja! Ich dachte ich sterbe als ich oben ankam aber ja,
ich bin den ganzen Turm hochgelaufen mit den kleinen Treppenstufen
Das ist eines der bekanntesten Gebäude in Deutschland und
du hast es gesehen, das ist doch was!
Einige Leuten würden sagen, das ist nicht korrekt, es gibt berühmtere Gebäude
Ja, ich habe ein Denkmal für Michael Jackson bei meinem Hotel
gesehen, das sah aus als wäre es ziemlich berühmt
Echt? Wo?
- Bei meinem Hotel, ich weiss nicht...
- Ah ok, ich auch nicht.
Das scheinte ziemlich berühmt zu sein... ist ja auch so typisch Deutsch
Also manchmal würdest du gerne mehr Zeit haben?
Auf jeden Fall, Es ist ziemlich durcheinander, ich war in
den letzten 3 Wochen in 4 verschiedenen Ländern
Und du bist in diesem Geschäft seit du 8 bist?
Ja, also wenn es um Musik geht so mit
8, es hat in der Grundschule angefangen
Habe Musikkurse in der Grundschule und High School gemacht und war im Chor
Und du hast auch mit 8 angefangen zu schauspielern oder?
Das habe ich gelesen, oder stimmt das nicht?
Ein bisschen jünger als 8, es war so mit 6
oder 7 als ich mit Schauspiel angefangen habe
Und du magst es immer noch?
- Ja ich mag es immer noch
Beides, Musik und Schauspiel sind 2 große Leidenschaften von mir
Ich liebe es zu schauspielern, ich mag es auf diese Weise kreativ zu sein
Und ich liebe die Musik, weil ich schon immer
einfach Fan von Musik und vielen Bands war
Was sagen deine Freunde dazu eigentlich? Sehen die dich überhaupt oft, oder genug?
Nein die sehen mich nie genug, ich wäre gerne mehr zu Hause
Aber es ist schön wenn ich zu Hause bin, denn
dann kann ich die ganze Zeit mit ihnen verbringen
Ich schätze und nutze die Zeit dann auch mehr, aber ich habe
jetzt auch Freunde überall auf der Welt, es ist ziemlich cool
Also brauchst du Facebook, Facebook ist für dich gemacht
Es ist auf jedenfall für mich gemacht, ich liebe es, ich
mache viele Fotos und stell sie dann auf Facebook
Und meine Freunde können so tun als wären sie da
Also dein Leben ist ein bisschen so wie das von Lilly in Hannah Montana
Auf jeden Fall, ihre Beziehung in der Sendung zu Miley
ist sehr ähnlich wie viele Beziehungen die ich habe
Meine beste Freundin und ich sind genauso wie
sie einfach gegenseitig besuchen wann man will
Es ist erstaunlich wie oft ich in der Serie
einfach alleine Zeit mit Billy Ray verbringe
oder einfach mit Robby Ray und der Steward Familie
esse, es ist einfach normal für sie
und so fühle ich mich auch mit vielen Freunden, wir haben eine enge Bindung
Kannst du eigentlich in anderen Ländern als den USA
auf der Stra0e laufen ohne erkannt zu werden?
Das ist glaube ich eines der vielen Missverständnissen von diesem Geschäft
Ich lebe immer noch in dem Haus wo ich aufgewachsen bin in
Los Angeles und ich habe noch Freunde von der Vorschule
oder Fußball, Camps und Schule... ich habe Freunde
von vielen Momenten in meinem Leben behalten
Ich habe auch durch meine Arbeit Freunde gefunden, es ist
leicht meinen normalen Lifestyle mit normalen Freunden zu behalten
Aber nur in deiner Nachbarschaft?
- Nein ich kann eigentlich überall hingehen
Ich gehe nicht mit Sonnenbrille und Kappen raus, ich
glaube, dass würde sogar mehr Aufmerksamkeit erregen
Aber ein paar Plätze vermeide ich, in Disneyland kann es
ein Albtraum sein, aber sonst ist es in Ordnung
Du brauchst also keine Verkleidung oder sowas, damit dich keiner erkennt?
Manchmal täuschen meine Freunde und ich Akzente vor, dann rede ich
anders und die Leute erkennen nicht, dass ich es bin
Und warum bist du jetzt in Europa?
Warum? ach das sind so viele Dinge... ich war erst in
Brasilien, hatte da ein paar Shows, die waren unglaublich
und dann bin ich nach London geflogen, war zu Gast bei TV-Shows, hatte Konzerte
Und dann Spanien bei den EMAs vor 2 Tagen... und jetzt Deutschland
Also ich war überall und versuche mein neues Album
zu promoten... und es macht total Spaß
Ist Europa noch wichtig für den Musikmarkt?
Klar, mein Produzent in Amerika ist aus London und
hat viel Ahnung von der europäischen Musik
Momentan sind Dance, Electro und Dubstep sehr angesagt und
da kommen viele gute Künstler aus Europa
Und ich bin ein großer Tinie Tempah Fan,
also es gibt viele coole europäische Bands
Ich glaube das war ein großer Einfluss für das Album,
also muss ich natürlich auch in Europa promoten
Also dein Album ist ein bisschen "für" Europa?
Etwas, ja. Ich habe so viel Inspiration von europäischen Bands, eine
meiner Lieblinge sind "Air", ein großer Einfluss für mich
Was hältst du von Europa? Als du das erste mal hier warst?
Es ist kalt, aber sehr wundervoll. Ich denke hier gibt es viel mehr Geschichte
Ihr habt so viele Museeen und man merkt richtig "Das ist Europa!"
In den Staaten ist alles neu, ihr habt
hier alte Architektur und das gefällt mir.
Also, dass ist so dein erster Eindruck?
Ja, also was ich "sehe." Ich bin von den Menschen erstaunt,
die meisten sprechen hier mehrere Sprachen. Dein Englisch ist toll!
Es ist verrückt, eine meiner Vertreter meines Labels spricht 4 Sprachen, es ist unglaublich
Ich spreche kaum anderthalb Sprachen
Ich spreche Deutsch und die Weltsprache, die Weltsprache ist nicht Englisch sondern schlechtes Englisch
Ich habe mit vielen Leuten geredet die Englisch nicht als Muttersprache
haben und die sagen es gibt viele verschiedene Arten
Es gibt Klassisches Englisch, London Englisch und Kanadisches Englisch
Oxford Englisch, Schottisches Englisch, Irisches Englisch, es ist verrückt
Es gibt sehr viele verschiedene Akzente
Verstehst du jeden Englischen Akzent? Oder hast du da auch Schwierigkeiten?
Ziemlich gut, aber in London musste ich öfters nachdenken was die
Leute sagten. Irisches Englisch ist auch schwer aber es geht.
Wie fühlst du dich in Europa?
Wie ich mich hier fühle? Wundervoll, willkommen, jeder ist so nett zu mir.
Ich habe das Glück hierher zu kommen seit ich klein bin. Ich
war in vielen Ländern und es ist immer ein Abenteuer
Irgendwie gibt mit jedes Hotel, jede Airline Schokolade. Ich
denke dass europäische Schokolade besser als unsere ist.
Ich weiß nicht, es gibt viele verschiedene Arten
- Ja,
die aus der Schweiz ist die Beste
Ja, das stimmt und wir in Köln haben ein Schokoladenmuseum.
Ihr habt ein Schokoladenmuseum? Wir haben einen Schokoladenfreizeitpark in  Pensilvania
- Echt?
Doch, das habt ihr nicht oder?
- Nein, wir haben Museen und ihr Freizeitparks
Ich werde die Freizeitparks besuchen wenn ich in den USA bin
Warst du schonmal da?
- Ja, ich war in New York
Das ist ein guter Ort um Amerika kennen zu lernen,
New York ist das Herz von den USA
Ok das nächste mal in New York, vielen Dank!
- Ja, danke!